kansas city i can't wait to get to your
wonderful town i'll be there january
20th through the 22nd get your tickets
for those dates and all dates at
ryansickler.com
the honeydew with ryan zickler
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pants
studios i am ryan sickler ryan
sickler.com ryan sickler on all your
social media uh i cannot thank you
enough for coming out and supporting the
night pants nation tour having a hell of
a fun time out there we've sold out
shows in indy
baltimore cleveland la jolla i mean it's
a hell of a time thank you so much
i will be hitting kansas city in january
january 20 to the 22nd kansas city
missouri get your tickets now
ryancichler.com
join the email list you'll be the first
to know about a bunch of upcoming events
and things uh make sure you're
subscribed to the youtube channel please
i say it all all the time it's nothing
to you and it's everything to us all
right just hit that subscribe if you're
watching and thank you for your support
the patreon show you guys are just
killing it with the stories
i mean holy [ __ ] it's five bucks a month
i'm not raising the price on it at all
it's gonna stay five
and um you get the honeydew a day early
ad free at no additional cost all right
and if you sign up for a year you get
over a month free so it actually is a
good deal to do that if you're in for
the long haul all right the
honeydewpodcast.com
is the website and if you or someone you
know has that story it has to be heard
please submit it to honeydewpodcast
gmail.com alright um you guys know we do
over here we highlight the low lights
and uh this is a little special holiday
honeydew here
um ladies and gentlemen it's a pleasure
to have this man back on the podcast
please welcome back to the honeydew just
potter everybody welcome back to the
honeydew what's up dude thanks for
having me thank you for coming in for a
holiday for myself
you should clap for yourself or what
happened dude
um plug whatever you want first uh well
uh the josh potter show every tuesday on
youtube please to be subscribing to that
also uh giggs i got milwaukee improv on
the 23rd of january and then a week
after that on the 30th uh west nyack
levity live
then on the 2nd of february pittsburgh
improv and the 3rd of february raleigh
improv so all those shows come on out
we're gonna add more at j underscore
potter on twitter and at josh underscore
potter on instagram that's where you can
find out about all that stuff and more
yeah go get tickets go check them out
yeah
thank you for coming in thank you for
closing out the year with me oh thanks
for having me my first video guest ever
nice little wrap-up yeah that's right
episode 13 right dude that's right
that's my lucky number so is it really
yeah
it works perfect hell yeah
um i don't know what number this is i
think i was episode 69 too that's always
a
good number to be
um
i wanted to talk to you just about
some holiday some i wanted to have a
lighthearted conversation
instead of a lot of the in-depth stuff
we get all the time sure but just about
some uh holiday honeydew moments because
i know i have plenty of mine and i was
like let me call josh potter and see
what he's yeah i've got a few of those
myself actually
we were talking about uh
well i was i bought my nephew a crazy
toy first time i got to do that i'm
gonna be the crazy uncle yeah that just
buys how old is he he's
about to be three okay so what'd you get
i got him a power wheels he loves a
spider-man cartoon on disney plus
patrick stump does the theme song it's
awesome show there's like eight episodes
and he knows like the words to all of
them isn't it crazy how they memorize
it's crazy like i don't
maybe we did i don't remember if i did i
mean if i did it was like ninja turtles
i guess maybe or something my mom always
would say she's like you've seen this
thing a thousand times i remember her
like yelling at me about that stuff but
now i feel like kids he knows how to
work an ipad like you wouldn't believe i
think he knows how to work it better
than i do my daughter's showing me [ __ ]
on my phone no no lie i swear to god i'm
like wait how'd you do that with that
maps right there she's like oh you just
put it in here this is ride shares i'm
like that's hilarious my father's wife
has this game and she like got to a
level and she's stumped and then one day
she caught him playing it and he like
got it past that level
yeah
and he like barely talks yeah it's crazy
but yeah so i bought him that but i was
thinking back to the power wheels i got
as a kid so power wheels for people that
don't know is it like those little
motorized jeeps or whatever yeah yeah
they make them
fit in them yeah they're like they have
like lambos now yeah i've seen and i was
gonna buy like some crazy ass lamp but i
was like that's more for me than it is
for him he doesn't want a [ __ ]
lamborghini so i got him the spider-man
car
and my brother-in-law's already like
where am i gonna [ __ ] put this
he's already mad at me i can't wait to
buy him like a drum set
that's what i used to do like crazy
finger paints and [ __ ] [ __ ] up the
house well did you have revenge on you
when you had a kid then did your i mean
people bought that's what you get for
kids you know what i mean i'll tell you
the revenge on me is those [ __ ] uh
their kits
uh jewelry of beads oh [ __ ] one
of those
[ __ ] features
you're vacuuming that [ __ ] up for i'd
rather white paint
i wouldn't because you're never you're
never
you never get them all
you'll step on one you're like [ __ ] i
never stop on paint yeah exactly
i remember when i was a kid we'd get
like uh my parents would buy us crazy
gifts every now and then my dad bought
us a nintendo like the 8-bit nintendo
and that came out and i wanted it so bad
and he got it but it was just the box
when i opened it and they acted like
there was like oh they forgot to put it
inside
it's like before viral videos or like
jimmy kimmel was [ __ ] with kids you
know and my dad just did that for fun
like there was no video
right yeah it was just a [ __ ] with us
for like the whole day
wait he did it for the whole day at the
end of the day he's like oh yeah
we found this in the hall
that's that is good that's cool
yeah exactly it was just
like look it's three hours later and
they're still upset maybe on instagram
now or whatever my dad would be on you
know good morning america or something i
remember um
we i mean up until our family split
apart which wasn't long into my life but
the memories i have we had good
christmases like my father i rode by
recently too my dad for two years bought
you could go in the woods to this little
nursery that grew trees and you could
chop your own tree down you bring a
[ __ ] chainsaw or an axe you chop your
own tree and it's like 10 bucks you know
what i mean you chop it you [ __ ] take
it it's the experience that you're
paying for
and uh my dad got two of them with the
roots and we put them in the house
decorated them and then he planted both
of them out front or my favorite house
and they they are in that house was a
basement and then two stories above that
those trees tower that so you got them
with the roots on them yeah you had a
burlap bag and you just kept it you know
wet and alive and then when you were
done with using it as a christmas tree
you took the whole root system and
everything took it out front dug a hole
buried it and that those are they're
towers now they're huge they're real
pine trees sure and they were small when
you bought them yeah regular like six
footer yeah oh it's in the roots weren't
like
not that big they were like i'd say a
good a good bundle
you had to take two hands to hold it and
carry it yeah
um
but i remember and i just found this out
recently this was pretty [ __ ] cool
too they used to have a the fire
department would have santa claus ride
by neighborhoods you know wave and throw
some candy and [ __ ] and uh we have this
whole video of this and and
i'm looking at the video and i don't see
my dad in the video and then my mother
told us recently that was him and i was
like get the [ __ ] out oh he was santa
like dude that made me cry
like so like
you know what i'd be like now like he
went out and did that you know
and it's not just
like for the whole neighborhood you know
what i mean and all you get is you get a
[ __ ] nerf
[Laughter]
i think about it too
having twins
dealing with my mom and my younger
brother sitting on top of that
[ __ ] fire truck in in costume
with those sirens blaring it was
probably the most peaceful yeah
[Laughter]
there was a couple times my grandpa did
the
my mom would try to like
perpetuate the belief in santa claus
so like we're getting older at this
point my mom would be like we got to
make him believe even harder or whatever
so she would get my grandpa to like
stand like that
oh yeah it's like she was like they're
starting to know we gotta like really
make them and she would do like videos
and stuff like she had a one of those
huge vhs video recorders
cam recorders or whatever they're called
and
like she would put in she goes santa
left the video and she'd put it in and
it'd be like my grandpa walking around
and he'd find the camera and be like no
looking or whatever and turn it off i'd
be like holy [ __ ] i can't believe we we
saw him that's crazy and then the next
year she had my grandpa like stand in
the backyard
and then she'd be like go to sleep quick
he's here he's here he'll be outside
yeah and he's like walking around in the
backyard
yeah he's like the sun wasn't even down
now kids can be like on
yeah yeah i had the am radio telling me
i'd be like they don't know i gotta call
it in or something i would want to call
the radio station or whatever but yeah
she would like perpetuate the ruse to
the point where
i found out it took me till sixth grade
yeah dude
and it was i remember i was kids weren't
telling you well here's the thing dude
like what other kids saw him when other
kids would tell me i go that's just the
bad kid who doesn't have santa come
anymore
and that's what their parents told about
your mom yeah yeah she would [ __ ]
plant that worm and then uh sixth
graders dude i remember me and my best
friend chris were sitting in science
class and mr d zak was his name
said something and him and i looked at
each like it was about how santa claus
was not real and him and i looked at
each other and were like
what like he was the only other guy that
still believed it yeah and we both were
like
and his mo because he was like an only
child his mom like went in and like lost
her mind on the teacher and everything
like that like how dare you vogue intel
and her and my mom became friends from
that moment on
well we it was look my daughter is in
first grade last year she was already
coming to me well now with the computers
i don't know but not only that you know
you got the older brothers and sisters
oh sure they're like no it's not real
and then like my older sister said and
that's what you got to tell them like
that's just because they're bad they're
not getting right you're too young to
ruin santa yeah if you already yeah yeah
that's it always sucks when one
figures it out or like loses that sort
of uh belief early on i feel like it's
like they're missing out on i'm glad it
took me forever maybe i don't know
[Music]
my virginity also
i lost that late too i don't know if it
all pushed everything the overton window
moved
it closed yeah yeah
i don't know if it's correlated
i am just very stunted as an adult too
so i don't know like i feel like i'm
just becoming 25 mentally
so
i'm 10 years behind in everything i was
saying it was the jewish kid in our
neighborhood that kept going around
telling everybody that santa wasn't real
but he wasn't doing he wasn't just
saying like my parents said it's not
right he was like rubbing it in people's
faces oh yeah he's an [ __ ] and uh
yeah and that's one kid just beat his
ass you know and then you find out later
like oh man he told me
yeah he wasn't wrong it was just the way
he was my mom would be like well that's
just because he's a jew heathen
throws heathen
he's a dastardly jew that's why he's
saying that everything was good for a
while christmas is i remember too we had
the old school original star wars action
figures
and my dad would tell us put a couple of
them save them whatever and my brothers
and i would tie a fishing line or shoe
strings around their necks and slam the
doors shut and pull the heads off you
know just torture them while we're
playing and [ __ ]
and then later
you hear that they're worth a lot of
money you're like oh you start going to
find greedo and [ __ ] like yeah we had
him yeah yeah
[ __ ] solos
see i'm on the opposite end of that
spectrum i saved all of them in the box
i wasn't allowed to play with them you
weren't allowed to play and my they're
still sitting in a box somewhere my
mom's like i can't find anyone to buy
these
original star wars i mean it's it's
stuff like that it's beanie babies it's
[ __ ] people all that [ __ ] she's been
on ebay oh yeah she doesn't know how to
do i know i don't know how to i mean
it's a delusion you might have small
you know it's funny i had her on my
podcast to talk about black friday
shopping with jeremiah now and jeremiah
said the same thing like why don't you
try selling these things and she's like
well they're only worth
as much as someone's willing to pay
and then i'm like well you gotta look
lady you can't just like sit around and
be like no one's coming to my door
asking me for
you know princess diana beanie babies
and [ __ ] like that so
i don't know what she's gonna do but one
day we'll i'll she'll die and i'll get a
bunch of
beanie babies and [ __ ] ninja turtles
and [ __ ] but starting lineups was
another one too do you ever have those
yeah the action figures i had a michael
jordan with hair
and what in my because he was like at
one point he had hair he had a little
bit he did did he have a little bit
though but they put him like put hair on
his head like you have a jordan with
hair yeah but i took it out i played
with it i'm talking with it and [ __ ] and
my dad was so pissed
he brings it up all the time he's like
you had the michael jordan with the hair
you had the michael jordan and michael
jordan's like 1989 1990s
yeah it wasn't even like the the regular
one it was with the hair
oh my god from the high school team he
was cut from for god's sake yeah
man
i knew for us i knew it all shifted when
my parents split
and then you start bouncing back between
homes right and i knew christmas was
different when um
were at my my dad's
uh mom's my grandmom that's what we call
my grandma you know that was grandma
sure and um we're leaving her place
and it's my dad and my two brothers me
and we're going to the civic center in
baltimore to watch a baltimore blast
game it's like right after the day after
christmas or something
we got all our presents from him and
everything it's in the back of our
station wagon our aspen station wagon
the limited edition wood paneling did
you see
[Music]
and am radio comes on and when you hit
the accelerator you hear it in the
speakers and [ __ ] like that you know
and we parked my dad would never pay for
a garage it was always i'm gonna find a
street spot we're like okay
and you know you go to an event like
that you're driving for 20 [ __ ]
minutes in the city trying to find a
spot you find like here here we go
and we come back after the game and you
just see your [ __ ] all over the ground
we're like nah oh
my dad's like uh oh and they stole
christmas oh no no you had christmas in
the car with you
yeah
why was this whole christmas oh i said
because it was like
just going to his place
he was put all our [ __ ] take us back to
mom's after the game jesus and they used
the baltimore city whatever they stole
christmas
yeah yeah
that's what he's like the grinch
what does he say clearly three people
[ __ ] too in the back you know
everybody had an umbrella bag for soccer
or whatever adidas back oh it was it was
loaded up for him all they had to do was
go in there grab this and this and this
they took it all i thought the grinch
was green dad not black
[Laughter]
you said that i don't know
we didn't know we didn't see them
could have been a green person
[Laughter]
yeah man baltimore city stole christmas
and i was like man shit's different from
here on out i could tell i can tell this
year the grinch is the supply chain
the supply chain stealing christmas this
year
oh man yeah that was brutal
that was definitely [ __ ] brutal i
remember to um
still believing or still questioning at
the time now we're questioning it and uh
looking out our bedroom window and
seeing what something red in the [ __ ]
sky and [ __ ] ourselves thinking that
that was rudolph yeah yeah rudolph it
was a 747
and i mean hustling under those covers
and then you're so excited you can't get
the [ __ ] surely oh my god i'm i'll
never i remember being like having so
much anticipation for christmas that it
would like i'd feel like i was gonna
explode and then all day on christmas i
couldn't enjoy it because i would be sad
that it would end right and i remember i
would just cry all enjoy the moment cry
you were i would be like tortured by the
fact that it was gonna end i'd be like
it's gonna end tonight and my mom would
be like well have fun then and i'd be
like no
it's over like i was
the depression after christmas even as a
kid was like crazy
but it had changed for me
it was just like because it was so much
fun like all my whole family would come
over this is when my grandparents were
still alive and we'd have like all my
cousins everybody all my aunts all my
uncles
all in one place to the point where
there's like probably 40 people
or so damn really yeah every day yeah
and we would go through and be like
oldest to youngest
youngest to oldest they'd open presents
you have to sit there and watch everyone
open their presents
and the family just kept growing and
growing so many grandkids that it got
crazy and it would be like a six-hour
thing
and they would be
strict about it like if you open your
presents and you were a kid they'd be
like you have to watch grandma open
seven hours from now you know what i
mean so we'd all sit there and then when
my grandparents died it was like my
parents or my mom and her siblings
didn't talk anymore so it's like we
never saw these people again so
christmas ended up be going like
completely downhill like somewhere i
don't know when i was like 13 or so 14
or so yeah say i was a little bit before
that for us but yeah but it was always
like so much fun to be and then and then
after that like
it just became like another day almost
you know what i mean like you'd have
like the morning or whatever but it
wasn't the whole like family gathering
like it was yeah it's interesting it was
the same way for us we had a really big
italian family and it would be
every one at my grandmom's house and
we'd stay there for a few hours and then
we'd all go including her to one of her
sister's houses and see everybody and
the cousins over there everybody hanging
out then we bounce all of us together
now going over to another
sister's house and it's all these great
aunts and cousins and just hanging out
man i
i really do miss it um
and i remember too like
what i didn't realize is my time my
family's italian so when i would date
girls and go to their [ __ ] and i'm like
you know where is this and this this
this one lady's [ __ ]
pouring rum on a cake and lighting it on
fire i'm like who the [ __ ] your god
you know where the hell are the stuffed
shells [ __ ] yeah
so italian where's that particularly
the cookies you have all the traditional
[ __ ] yeah plus right it's not like
you're just getting this you want your
turkey your mashed potatoes your [ __ ]
ham at easter whatever it's all there
sure but it's also all this [ __ ] over
here and i was like i'm gonna eat off
this side of the table yeah
did you have it you obviously had a
kid's table oh you had enough right we
had so many people
growing up that it was just it was
insane it was like looking back you're
like oh man that was almost like torture
or a lesson in discipline or something
to like open your presence and then you
can't even like go and play with them
you have to wait
through all of the people obviously the
gifts would get less but it would get
really like the grandparents would get
the most gifts probably that's why your
shit's still in boxes you got oh you
were over about you were able to forget
i even got it yeah
by the time
and then it would get it toward the end
though it would get frayed like i said
so many grandkids were being born that
it was like
you know it was a small fortune to buy
presents for everybody so it had to be a
policy like either i have to buy
presents for everybody or i buy presents
for none right so then you start getting
less as you get older you know you'd be
like i think i was like you know 14 or
so or something like that and i would
get like three gifts i'd be like okay
so now i'm just like a prisoner to this
process i'm in the middle somewhere and
i'm going to sit around here and watch
everyone open presents i'm just going to
come to me i'm going to be like cool
socks
you know
yeah and then i just still sit there for
the rest of it it was it started getting
torturous you know as we got older but i
remember um
once we found out santa wasn't real it
definitely took some shine off of
christmas
so my brother and i would sneak down
at like three or four in the morning
when christmas was set up we knew our
parents would be asleep
exhausted and we go down there with a
little roll scotch tape and we would
just tear a corner like we got the
millennium ball and then tape it back
you know what i mean like got a baseball
bat my mom would continue even though
she knew we knew she would still like
save some presents to put out until like
three in the morning and write santa on
them and i'd be like thanks for the such
and such and she'd be like santa brought
that and i'd be like okay thank you yeah
yeah yeah he did he did he brought that
for you that wasn't me that you'd like
maintain that ruse despite knowing we
knew it all changed obviously my dad
died like right after thanksgiving and
then that was it i can remember
moments of christmases
i can feel the heat still from the
fireplace all that [ __ ] once my father
died
i i swear to you i can't pinpoint
a [ __ ] christmas beyonce you know
what i mean like i'm just having that
now like i'm like oh that was my when i
was eight that christmas was when i was
10. now i mean now but since he died i
can't right i can't now once my daughter
was born that's when it began for me
again you know so i but it's still
you're talking about
30 [ __ ] years of christmases and i
can't remember like one where i did
something where i'm like [ __ ] yeah
christmas yeah i haven't gone home for
christmas since the first year that i
moved here
and i've been here for christmas the
whole time and one one christmas i went
to tom's house but the other than that
the other couple i couldn't tell you
what i did last year i don't even right
i told you i just remembered what i did
for new year's like two seconds ago
last year it was just such a blur yeah
last year for us was like i think i
could twitch streamed on christmas i
might do that again this year uh i don't
know but i um new years was always like
a holiday that i worked on since i was
like
working in radio even because i would
service industry people out there bless
you all always work in the [ __ ]
holidays i know working in hotels i
never had a day off i would either be
doing like when i first started radio i
would be doing like
the board production like board hopping
like a an event during the midnight ball
drop or then i started hosting those and
then i started doing comedy shows
every new years because i thought like
what else am i gonna do like it's cool
i'm making money i still get to like
hang out and drink or whatever and
and have fun like doing comedy during
new year's was like the best way to do
new year's i thought for a long time
yeah well you're also you're amongst the
the masses who are all out there
drinking you can join them if you feel
like it work at the same time it was
pretty unique thing the new year's out
here is weird i'll tell you because
it'll be like five four three two one
and then it's like last call
yeah back home it's foreign
you know you just watched it yeah yeah
but it's just weird like go to go home
at one life on tape delay yeah it's
straight well that's true too yeah
you're watching it throughout the east
coast and then the midwest and etc so
yeah it's weird out here west coast new
year's but there was one year i did uh
it wasn't a ball drop it was a guitar
hard rock cafe does like a guitar drop
down this
giant building
and uh i was hosting it so i had to go
out like it's a stage there's bands and
people are out in the crowd
and so when it came to do
the countdown
the whalers were on stage you know where
the whalers are like ziggy marley i
guess
i guess
yeah and his kids doing it now so
they're on stage they're all
[ __ ] blazing and they're up there
they're playing like
jamming or whatever they're doing
and they're like it's meant they're
about they're telling me they're like
it's about to be midnight and i'm like
well they're playing a [ __ ] song what
do you want me to like get out there and
they don't i don't know where i'm at
right so like i just go out there and
i'm like
uh ten
you're interrupting the way yeah yeah
yeah he's [ __ ] cute well bob marley's
dead but it's the kids yeah well they're
supposed to be done they're supposed to
know
they're on weeds oh yeah yeah they're
just like pajamas i'm like oh [ __ ] dude
so i run out there and i don't know
where i'm at in the cat like i don't
have a precise
atomic clock to tell me like
start counting down now they're just
like it's going the things started
coming down and i'm like uh eight no you
started yeah yeah yeah dude
randomly just like because it was
already going so i just
dude i totally blew it like there you go
you were about four seconds late
[Laughter]
and i got i never did that again
the next year they got someone else
like you blew the whole gig the whole
gig was the countdown this is the
countdown i'm like well you hosted those
job was 10 seconds yeah they're like it
was yeah but that's the most important
part and you [ __ ] up oh god that is
hilarious yeah the new year started at
1201 for us
i was like it's not so i was like
[ __ ] whalers they ruined my 500 gig
or whatever it was at the time and it
was like that was important to me and i
was [ __ ] pissed at them and i
remember i ended up like doing a couple
shots afterwards and literally just they
gave me a hotel room in that hotel that
the event was at and i just went up to
the hotel room it couldn't have been 12
25 and i just took my suit off and just
laid in the bed and went to sleep that
was it yeah that was the end of my new
year i woke up at like 3 a.m i go oh man
i really [ __ ] that new year up
you know i didn't even do anything fun
when it comes to skin care since i've
been a teen i've always had skin i was
uncomfortable with from the pimples to
blackheads all of it bags under my eyes
everything i've tried everything going
all the way back over all these years
with skin care and disco is my new
favorite this goes a clean skincare
brand based in austin texas all disco
products are created specifically for
male skin issues like under eye bags
dark circles acne razor burn oily skin
dry skin and wrinkles products are easy
to use effective and affordable they
take the guesswork out of taking care of
your skin the stick is formulated with
caffeine peptides and moisturizer to
transform those under eye bags after a
long night of partying gaming working or
whatever your advice may be the
applicator is easy to use you just roll
it on under your eyes you pat it lightly
and boom you're good to go if you want
to check out this go and try their
incredible skincare products for
yourself we have a special offer for my
honeydew audience go to
letsdisco.com
honeydew or enter honeydew at checkout
for 30 off your first order that's
letsdisco.com honeydew for 30 off your
first order thank you disco dudes skin
care is not just for the ladies trust me
now
let's get back to the duke i told this
story before but i know i've never told
you this so when i first moved here
i was a production assistant for what
was then fox family channel it later
became abc and now i think it's like
free form or something like that
and we started this thing then when i
was there we created this they did and i
was working on it called 25 days of
christmas it was going to be this
promotion which i think still runs all
through every version of whatever fox
family was and the first year
i'm a production assistant and they're
doing this
giveaway it's 25 000 giveaway
and it's open to anyone in the
continental united states okay
and
they need a pa to go on the shoot with
this producer named allison who was the
[ __ ] she and i used to go
she was like i'm going to see tom petty
at the film where i was like [ __ ] yeah
and [ __ ] i've always wanted to go to
fillmore and i would love to [ __ ] see
tom petty we road trip up
so um
she's like i want ryan to come and i was
like awesome and she's like it could be
anywhere ryan i was like [ __ ] yeah
hopefully it's florida yeah you know
hopefully somewhere warm you know let's
go
and um this lady wins and it's three
mile island [ __ ] pennsylvania oh no
three mile island it's a trailer why did
they pick her does she want oh she just
won oh that goes the show it's not
rigged
that's what i'm saying i'm like wait
of all the [ __ ] places where you can
go that's like going to fallujah i mean
you might as well just go to a war zone
you're going to get radiation so like
that's where we're going like okay and
i'm like what's the what's the deal like
okay the the gist of the promo is that
gary coleman has been hired and agreed
to uh play this oversized elf and it's
basically this elf is delivering uh oh
and oversized
maybe he wasn't but the check he was
delivering was oversized because i
misspoke yeah okay uh he's delivering
like one of those humongous prices right
style checks right the whole the check
is oversized he's average for an elf yes
and he's this plight of him taking this
check across country to wherever because
it could be anywhere right
and um
they're gonna shoot him he's gonna fly
and then we're gonna be like literally
in and out in one day we're gonna no i
don't even think we're spending a night
wow
so
they um like you're going the ladies in
three mile island here's your flight
info here's gary stuff you guys are
flying in
um a little bit ahead of him like okay
oh boy and then when we land
yeah gary gary missed his flight we're
like did he miss it did he miss it
did he miss it or did he see the where
it was going so we're like how about did
you talk to the driver that was supposed
to pick him up and the driver was
covering his ass that driver was like i
got out of my car i've i've done this
with this guy before i went to his door
i knocked multiple times
no answer i'm telling you he just did
not show he's a no-show he's not late
he's a he's ghost yeah
so
but he's supposed to be here today and
now he's not and we're shooting in a few
hours
and they're like allison looks at me and
she knew i did comedy and stuff we were
super cool and she's like
will you be the elf and i was like nope
there's i'm definitely not doing i'm not
[ __ ] doing that she's like listen
maybe we could get you your sag after
car like i don't give a [ __ ] i'm not
doing this she's like we could we could
figure out a way to get you paid for
this though if you're going to perform
on camera then they got to pay you more
than your pa rate which was a hundred
dollars a [ __ ] yeah sure okay
like i don't want to do it and
again we're super cool we blaze and
stuff she's like just put the [ __ ]
clothes on
and do they even fit you no dude i put
his little pants on it's like i mean
it's all my nut sacks that's right yeah
she's like getting on camera yeah yeah
yeah she's like
she's like will you [ __ ] so i walk
out of the bathroom dressed like that i
mean the shirts she is dying
and she's like if we can go to the mall
and get you some clothes would you do it
and i'm like no i don't want to do this
she's like please i'm like fine but you
gotta call them and get me something
paid or whatever taft hartley it was
called if to get you right into sag
after or i don't even think it was sag
after then i think it was just sag
so or aft whatever the [ __ ] so
yeah we'll pay him we'll try to help him
with that
so we go to the mall and um
we had to get gap kids
and i couldn't remember something
happened where it was
oh no we had to take his clothes back
the gap kids we go to me we get gaps and
we get a smile
and it had it was where we had to get
his [ __ ] again kids that's why we were
there i forgot
so we go to gap
get my [ __ ]
and then i go all right if i'm gonna do
this i want to be able to call the shots
on like what these little things we are
we're doing so
like while we're driving to the mall
there's for some reason there's an
outhouse a little [ __ ] porta potty in
the middle of a cornfield and i was like
i want to come out of that with the
check like i just took a [ __ ] in there
and like okay we shot that me coming out
like i took a [ __ ] in this
random thing the van broke down so i'm
like laying under it and they're
shooting me with my little elf shoes out
and [ __ ]
and then we get to the house and i've
met the lady and everything and i'm
gonna be honest like the trailer park
house she was in a trailer and not the
house and
it it hit home for me because i've never
lived in a trailer but i've lived in an
apartment that might as well have been a
[ __ ] trailer because it was just
like a double square living room here
a tiny square kitchen next to it and
then it's literally a hallway yeah and
off that hallway are rooms one two three
and that's [ __ ] it right
and this was
i mean we were a step above that in that
apartment i felt like
and we had kerosene heaters did you ever
use those
um you know the ones i'm talking about
yeah but i mean big floor ones right
right yeah and she had them but you know
my brothers again this is something that
if your kid falls and hits it they're
gonna right you're ruining their face
yeah you know but what do my brothers
and i do we're over there spitting
loogies on it watching it sizzle yeah
because we're just [ __ ] big boys
you know we're in [ __ ] elementary
school and [ __ ] filling it middle school
filling it with kerosene yeah kerosene
yeah kid's
an entire complex of people so
you know she has to now we have to tell
her of course and she's i wish we were
rolling when you tell her but they have
to tell her ahead of time for legal
reasons sure
she's obviously not a good actress of
course
and now i'm out on this porch and it's
by the way it's [ __ ] pencil it's
freezing
sweats and rubber elf shoes i am in a
smock i'm [ __ ] in a turtle i'm
freezing
and almost out there like go do it again
i'm going to tell like oh my god and
while i'm out there the [ __ ] school
bus pulls up oh and all the kids see me
and they are going nuts like in a good
way yeah they can't believe it mr ralph
mister
they don't even know why a [ __ ] elf
is on the porch in a trailer park you
thought i'd be like what the [ __ ]
happening mr
they're ellen i'm just like you gotta be
[ __ ] kidding me i thought they were
like you're a little tall being elf
they're just [ __ ] with you the whole
time
couldn't get over that something festive
was different than santa was in the
neighborhood you know the camera is
probably yeah
and the kids come in and i got to stand
there and do the
check with them and i got my photos of
it the thing ran i remember a friend i'm
back in maryland visiting some friends
like i just saw you on five and i said
no you didn't
like yes i did i could not i was not me
i don't even work there like boy that
guy looked just like you i said it
wasn't fire
but it was that's good you have a twin
too you could blame it he doesn't look
like oh that's right okay
that's hilarious and then
i get back and what does gary coleman do
gary coleman starts lying saying i was
there and you guys [ __ ] up and so what
do they do they paid them they pay gary
coleman what did they do to me nothing
they didn't pay you they didn't pay me
they didn't help me with sag or after
whatever the [ __ ] it was they didn't
give me a [ __ ] day off nothing my god
nothing [ __ ] so big gary [ __ ]
coleman got paid
that's gross dude
i did uh i did like um
my last girlfriend and i broke up on new
year's eve
because i
did a comedy show on new year's eve yeah
because i did a comedy i i like i said i
was doing comedy shows every year
and i did it was me so dan soder and
this guy james davis
the three of us were doing like a
weekend and new year's eve fell in it so
it was like three shows it was like it
was new year's eve was always a big
check you know that's why i love doing
it too
and i always pick comedy gigs over
girlfriends at the time and so i was
like yeah i'm working new year's eve so
i don't know she's like well can i come
and i was like no i mean it's like i'm
gonna be on stage during i can't even
like kiss you at midnight you're just
gonna be sitting alone
in the showroom like why bother she's
like well i want to go i want to go i'm
like all right fine and then that day
she's like i'm sick
and i'm like okay well then don't come
she's like no i'm still gonna come
and i'm like not a good idea
but whatever
so she
so she comes to the show
and afterwards
you know we do the midnight thing
i say hello to her and then like
afterwards we're just like waiting to
settle up and like we're blazing in the
green room and like i don't know 20
minutes go by and she's like when are we
leaving i'm like we
are not ever leaving i'm i got to drive
these guys they want to do stuff i'm
going to go with you know like i'm the
emcee i got to drive the headliners
around or whatever i got to take them
back to the hotel
she's like well uh i just i don't feel
good i want to go home i'm like go home
then i will see you when i get home
and so i just broke up with her
yeah
we've been dating for like years and i
was just like this is the end this is
the done like i'll see you when i get
home if you want to talk about it but we
are done broke up with her right then
and there it was i haven't had a
girlfriend since then that was like
ringing in 2016 or 2015 or something
like that it's not that long ago oh i
guess that's not that long ago but yeah
it's uh well it's more than five years
at this point i think but yeah it was
just like i realized in that moment i'm
like i don't know if i'm gonna love a
girl more than i love doing this
you know
i know people don't get it because you
know but also a lot of people don't love
their jobs that's true too i remember
that a lot of people hate their jobs
they can't understand how in the [ __ ]
you could love your job and pick what
they view as work
over them because they don't like what
they do is they must assume you don't
yeah i guess that's true yeah i mean
it's especially somebody doesn't have
any passion for anything
dating those types of women is like
soul-sucking when they don't have
anything to really latch on to and then
they latch on to you
and your [ __ ] and you're like whoa i'm
still
like i can't be the uh shining star in
this relationship here you know what i
mean i'm still trudging it out on my own
so yeah that it just was a real
eye-opening new year's eve that one for
sure
going into it going like we are done
happy new year start
a brand new year off single thank you
for the new year
[Laughter]
i did a gig one time you'll appreciate
this i got hired brian baldinger my man
brian bulger is the one that booked me
for this
i was the i can't remember what year it
was now
but i was the lapd robbery and homicide
units christmas detective okay for a
role yeah yeah um and it was like
they're a corporate basically but it's
for the lapd robbery and homicide units
christmas party okay
excuse me it's
it's just on the other side of downtown
off the 10. it's like a country club up
on the hills real i've never i've been
past it a million times court's never
been up to it but sure really nice place
and uh it's probably 2 000
[Music]
excuse me six or seven it probably is
and um
they're telling me like
one guy
one guy from the entire department is in
contact with me and he's telling me say
this about that you can say this about
this person and i was like but i knew
that i was like i'm not gonna do any of
that he's like you can talk about this
guy because he's like the tech guy i was
like no no no
um but language whatever he's like do
whatever you want so i get there and
they're like we have food you can come
and eat i'm like i already know what
your food is at the buffet i'm not gonna
[ __ ] with that yeah yeah maybe after
we'll see yeah yeah yeah if i get there
and you're gonna do you know 45 minutes
i'm like okay
and um
it's middle of the day it's like three
o'clock two o'clock
all
brightly lit
there are babies running around on the
floor
children all over that yeah christmas
tree huge over here in the corner and
then when i get there the guy i haven't
been dealing with says
no foul language no this no that no
nothing i'm like what the [ __ ]
so i get up and there's a little old
school podium you know i mean like a
principal's podium up there i would [ __ ]
and i go grab the mic and i go to start
walking the stage that [ __ ] mic
went about this far
not good no you guys don't have a mic i
can move like no it's one of those
podiums
as soon as i bet they're here
so now i'm stuck standing dead still for
40. giving a speech
and all
first thing i said was look they they
don't want me to say they told me i
can't cuss i hear all the rules they
told me i was like you guys are eating
sandwiches over dead bodies but i guess
i can't say [ __ ] up here and they die
and then i just go all right and what i
had done
was research of all the open cases that
are still out there and i was like
all right biggie who's on it who's on
where
he's over there i'm like where are we at
rfk apparently is still unsolved who's
on that he's over there
that's so crazy
so that's all i did for like 45 minutes
was talking about open cases and who's
on them and [ __ ] that's great would you
just google them at the time yeah i was
looking i just wrote open unsolved cases
la uh police department they would have
things in there like still unofficial
and they were there laughing they're
like yeah we don't know it's like no we
don't they got the bulletin board where
it's like a clown on it he's supposed to
be working on it now he's here that's
that scene in dark night where they're
like
we're following all the leads of batman
and it's like abraham lincoln's on the
board or whatever
that was that was tough but one of the
worst ones i ever did was um full charge
and i matt folsharon and i did this
christmas gig it was same time too it
was right around the same time same year
i think it was because i was
um i was living in uh the same apartment
when this happened that i remember it
was so bad
he picked me up where i was in sherman
oaks when we go out to like the deep
valley and it's this uh armenian dentist
and he he had a he threw a party for his
patients and his employees like a bunch
and so it's a it's a big ballroom like
where i come from in maryland we have
these places called martin's west
martin's east and they're just ballrooms
okay you know what i mean it's a
building it's got like four of them in
there and they don't have proms there or
weddings they're just a big-ass ballroom
and that's what this [ __ ] is
and it's big and they got a live band
and stuff and then again we're each
doing 20 minutes and i got to go first
and i go up and i mean first of all most
people don't even
understand what we're saying sure
because it's like
muff like the speakers are in the yeah
also there's a language barrier for sure
oh boy you know
iran because the shitty ass ballroom
that too like you could not
you couldn't this this mic you could you
could move left or right but you
couldn't step forward it was crazy
but forks are clanking the tables and
[ __ ] and there's just one table and they
are [ __ ] loving it
everyone else doesn't give up like you
they're talking
way loud but this one table of four
right here is eating it up and that's
just that's i just they're stuck in with
those yeah to this day i've never
it's a set's never felt longer i'm on
stage going how much longer full charge
you'd be like 13. i'm like that was good
[Applause]
five jokes
i did five jokes in seven minutes dude
paid us
this these four went over and told him
how much they loved it so he was happy
paid us and i was back home probably in
like two hours two and a half hours back
[ __ ] home was awful but the money was
alright that's the thing like those
shitty like holiday party gigs they like
you know in the years past those used to
be like you make a nut doing those but
they were torture i did a
holiday party for like it ended up being
like this bowling league had their like
annual banquet and holiday party or
whatever
and they did the same thing they like
rented out a room
in like a vfw or something like that
and it was like four of us we had to
fill an hour
and which is nothing you'd think right
20 minutes each but yeah like you said
it was like torture and i remember
during my set i went like second last
one of the these are adults middle like
older than me adults middle age you know
50s
they're now by the time i go on stage
it's like maybe 40 minutes in
they're wasted
and
now they're
ignoring everything that's going on like
you're just talking into noise and so
like the two guys that went up before me
they were like i just talked for the
time they're not even paying attention
and it's like four or five full tables
of people when i went up now they're
throwing things at each other like
children
these are employees who know each other
these are like people like adults like
in a bowling league or whatever like oh
yeah you know like eight teams in a
bowling like some bowling league had
this holiday party
so this table is a team and this they're
throwing [ __ ] at each other while i'm on
stage and i like all of a sudden became
an old man i'm like are you children
like i started like lecturing them for
throwing
roles and [ __ ] at each other and like
for there was like a split second where
they like kind of were ashamed
and then one guy was like [ __ ] you and
he just threw like a roll at me yeah and
then i go oh right and i just walked off
and i told the guy i'm like you better
[ __ ] pay me regardless like i had
[ __ ] how long were you in there i was on
stage probably like
by the time i got off 15 minutes
probably not even 20. and they
like i've derailed the set at like
probably 10 to like a lecture yeah and
then i'm trying to like get them back by
making fun of them
and they kind of were like like i said i
like thought i was winning at one point
and then the one guy just like and then
they all laughed at what he did and i go
well i've lost
yeah that's an l right there and i got
the i did get paid and we're drinking
after these days i would have just been
especially with your skill set just
calling color commentary oh sure no i
mean i would have [ __ ] i would have
had put on them biscuits i would have
had more fun yeah with it now but back
then i was like i don't know the courage
for insiding a rock oh sure i don't know
what they he gets hurt he was
encouraging it he told him to throw it a
bit who knows how we're gonna go they
were so lit these people
to the point where afterwards i was
stuck there i had gotten a ride with one
of the other guys and he's like waiting
to settle up for all of us because he's
like i'll make sure we get paid don't
worry because i was like they better
[ __ ] pay us i'm not leaving here
until they do so he's like i'll take
care of it so we're like waiting there
afterwards amongst these people at the
bar and they'd come up and be like oh
man that was great
and you're like what did you watch
you're like oh we had so much fun
i'm like
all right then i guess like
what do you all do for fun yeah yeah i
was like that was the most miserable
i want to go jump into traffic right you
also realize people don't know how to
have fun yeah like that was fun
they were like we had a food fight
they're all tossed you know they're all
drunk and i'm just like drinking beer
with these people they're like wasn't
that the best i'm like no
uh it was the worst day of my life
oh my god but yeah i got hit with the
face with a roll too i'm like all right
i'm done i just walked off stage i've
told this now you're making me this is
not holiday but this is a food fight
story it's the it's the greatest food
fight in the history
of i'm gonna say high schools in
maryland
because
i have uh friends that i went to high
school with whose children now go there
oh okay and it's still the rule is still
in place in 1990
i'm a junior
my buddy mark penn at the times a senior
and for a few weeks school hadn't been
in in long but for a few weeks there was
a rumor
that this massive
[ __ ] foo fight was going to go down
and
it was like fourth period and i remember
we used to have we had a three-tiered uh
cafeteria one a little smaller area
topped here down to a little bit bigger
and then the bottom was the biggest and
that's where the food was and the snacks
and all that [ __ ]
and we had the early lunch that we hated
because it was like a i don't know like
10 50 or something yeah
yeah the whole [ __ ] day yeah
but that's the one we have and
um everyone's been talking about it and
mark peng got tired of hearing that
[ __ ] and mark pat's like i'm
starting that [ __ ] today
if you do it if you throw i'm gone i'll
go but i'm not starting and he's like
i'm gonna start it
so that day we sit up on the
on the top tier
it's pizza friday we got our milkshakes
everything
and mark penn is sitting where i am and
i'm sitting where you are and the next
tier is behind me and the whole floor is
down there and mark pen just looks at me
and doesn't say anything and he takes
his chocolate milkshake and he just
[ __ ] chucks that much
it is a goddamn chocolate milk
and it hit that bottom
foreign i'm telling you it was like a
[ __ ] trigger everybody whoa i threw
my [ __ ] and then free for all shit's
hitting the [ __ ] wall and sliding
down i'm like oh my lions it's all
coming down here and people are going
nuts teachers are running out the kids
are coming out of class it was like
instant instant wow everyone had been
waiting and when that [ __ ] milkshake
hit
people are flipping tables off god
getting hit
cups of corn
pudding you [ __ ] name it burgers
fries all the [ __ ] shit's coming
everywhere
and i'm telling you i think school
started what september is this might be
i really don't remember but it's it's
not long it might be november yeah it's
like pretty early in the season we have
to have lunch and silence the rest of
the year we can't talk in silence
silence milkshakes are banned for the
school oh my god not just us the school
and that's 1990 and they are still
banned today 2021 bro they probably
banned them in the still banned today
these girls hit me up like my daughters
go to school there and those milkshakes
are still bad
there's probably another reason i mean
they probably would have banned them
anyway when michelle obama came along
maybe but that was years of money making
on milkshakes
they were like [ __ ] this milkshake
machine it's expensive yeah maybe i uh i
never i that was like my worst nightmare
as a kid was a food fight i never it
never appealed to me i'm like i don't
want to get food on oh [ __ ] man i
couldn't wait i never i was always like
god i hope there's never a food fight oh
it just happened i would like to watch
one
[Laughter]
it was so much fun it was so much what
i'll tell you another this is a
thanksgiving one
um
you know this is after our dad's dead
and we go over my aunt margarites and
she's got her little family and stuff
there and we're chilling and one of her
daughters is married to this [ __ ]
just a real dirtbag piece of [ __ ] like
in every sense just greasy
dirt under his nails or whatever we're
all having dinner at the thanksgiving
table when this [ __ ] slides his
seat back just a little bit off the
table
starts clipping his toenails oh no
toenails are flying
and my brother and i look at him listen
we just sat down at the table my brother
and i
we got up we didn't even say anything to
anybody went right over to the trash i
dropped my whole plate in the [ __ ]
trash and we just walked right out the
[ __ ] front door i was like did that
[ __ ] just happen right toenails he's
clipping toenails and thanksgiving
they're flying they're flying
hey
ten points
for real that's disgusting
you you definitely have lived alone way
too long yeah it's way too [ __ ] long
well i mean i've lived alone for a very
long time now to the point of like
uh mental breakdowns and i would never
still do that no yeah
what do you do for the holidays is your
place decorated for christmas right now
um i have some lights
but not really we have like a little
tree see i've always even
like obviously everything lost its shine
i the the the toughest christmas
ever was obviously right you know a few
days weeks after my father died but not
just because of that but also
like all these really nice people
donated from the school donated clothes
but it makes you feel sure it makes you
feel like even a bigger [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ] sure you know what i mean it makes
you feel like a loser and i remember too
this one stuck in my head
i was i'm a maryland kid they're sending
michigan i wore a michigan wolverines
[ __ ] sweatshirt for a while just
because it was like a donut and i felt
i don't know i felt like a loser putting
those clothes on right i like where they
came from yeah and i knew they came from
a good place sure for a good reason but
also it feels like you're defeated
once you put it on it feels like you've
lost yeah you know i don't know how if i
could make sense no it does because it's
like you know
why you have this yeah piece of clothes
and then you're going back to school and
people are staring at you like we got
you that i'm like oh it was really yeah
it was really nice thing that my dad
used to do but like my grandma lived in
this apartment building and there was
like
a family that lived across or downstairs
from her or something and it was
definitely like an illegal uh immigrant
sort of situation they were uh they were
mexican family and there was like two or
three kids and my dad would always like
make me like he would buy toys for them
and then make me deliver them and i
always just felt strange i'm like i
don't know these kids but i mean it was
doing a nice thing but it just made me
feel like you do wonder
just because i knew and they were like
the parents were always very thankful or
whatever but uh
on a lighter note for christmas time i
thought about this after our family kind
of dissipated and stopped doing that
whole thing we started going to
like what i consider my actual family
now like my actual family my blood
relatives i don't hang out with them at
all anymore
and
now i have like
my mom's best friend through most of her
adult life
i always called her my aunt shelley and
then her son is like my best friend
growing up since we were like babies
so i consider them like my cousins you
know what i mean and then their families
my my cousins too so we'd celebrate
christmas with them like after i started
becoming a in high school age
and around the time like junior senior
year
i don't know how it picked up but we
started playing beer pong
so it'd be me and my cousin drew versus
our dads in beer pong and our my the
first year we did it i barely drank i
never really drank
and
our dads murdered us in beer pong
and so i'm blackout drunk and i remember
we're about to like leave it was all
done and i'm shit-faced
and
like 17 or 18 years old and i just was
like stumbling around and i thought i
was going into the bathroom to puke and
i ended up puking in the dog's bowl
thinking it was the toilet ah and i left
this giant
pile of puke
in the dog's bowl
thinking it was the toilet trying to dog
he probably did i don't even know i
don't even know but it was like i
couldn't live that down and then we know
every year we kept playing this beer
pong or like drinking games we started
doing drinking games with everybody
and you know i started partying a little
harder as the years went on so i was
able to keep up but
like maybe two three years later more of
the cousins are getting involved
and
there is a scandal because
somebody puked in the bathroom
and used my aunt's
white monogrammed towels to like wipe up
the puke
yes no you know you do you don't do that
with the showtime the show like the
christmas time show towels
puke on this pure white towel
to this day
i walk people think i did it and i
swear up and down i did not do it
but no one will believe me
who do you think did it then i i have no
idea i don't even know at first i was
like no cause like i didn't do it so i
go like i thought they were lying but
they showed me the towel i'm like i
don't know i have no idea it could have
been my little sister it could have been
so i got the because i was the dog bowl
puker
i was the natural suspect
and so to this day like i just saw them
for thanksgiving everybody and they're
like remember when you puked and wiped
up the top the puke with my beautiful
towels and i was like that wasn't me i
live i mean i'll deny it up and down
because i know it was me and i would
admit it if it was by this point you
know hopefully somebody on there on
their death bed will throw that out for
you or something it was me i'd be like i
knew it
i'll tell you i just had a i had a great
time in cleveland it's my first time in
cleveland first time doing hilarities
which is a [ __ ] amazing club sam by
the way over there
[ __ ] thank you brother for everything uh
eva came ever comes and does helps me do
merchandise too and we went to um the
christmas story house i posted about it
and stuff
and then we get there and we buy tickets
for a tour we go to the [ __ ] merch i
mean they are making yeah yeah yeah
cause this is the
high season for that team yeah i'm
saying i'm
f we're fortunate to be there at
christmas for the christmas story house
um so go in the merch and they've got
every hat in the [ __ ] movie i mean
everything from the movie is in that
damn store it's it's insane and i was
like you know i just want to [ __ ]
smoke a joint out in front of the
christmas story house so i mean we're
waiting for the tour we're going to get
the tour i'll smoke at a joint and then
i'm looking at the clock and stuff and
i'm like
i don't need to take a tour i was on the
porch got my lamp yeah it's not the
actual set yeah i don't want to go
through this it's just the facade of the
house yeah
and i was like you know what
and eva always clowns me because she's
right on a macro level if i say i'm
gonna do something i do it on a bigger
level of things on a smaller level i'll
be let's go here this weekend and then
i'm like can we just [ __ ] you qualify
it yeah you're just not yeah
[Music]
so we're smoking a joint i'm looking at
the house and she's like what are you
thinking and she just starts laughing
she's like you don't want to do the tour
d i was like i don't know we might be a
little bit you know what once you
realize the two it's not like this is
where ralphie shot his eye out you know
what i'm saying like the the set it's
not the set of the feelings i know what
that all is about so i'm like no i don't
want to do it
so she's just laughing she's like you
[ __ ] kill me so i go but do you care
because if you want to do it i'm in
she's like i only wanted to do this
because you said i was like great so we
go inside i'm like let me find a family
with some kids and so i find this couple
and they got three kids and i'm like hey
you guys want to go because i could see
they were like i go here's pre-paid
tickets i just got to get out there are
you sure i'm like yeah and then i look
at the three kids and i'm like i
probably just made you spend more
they're pissed they're like oh god
that's good
body that you didn't want us i go look
if you can't afford it or whatever just
give them to somebody that wants them we
gotta get out of here
but i always try to do something nice
with it or whatever yeah sure sure
dude this has been fun man thank you for
coming on no problem thanks for having
me i actually lived by that uh christmas
story house yeah i used to live out that
way did you go buy it a lot i went i
mean i i i didn't do the tour but i i
definitely took pictures out front of it
all the time but i lived there mostly in
the summer i le i moved away
around christmas time so it was like i
remember it started snowing i go this is
nice here oh well peace out cleveland
yeah i mean look [ __ ] your winters
cleveland [ __ ] everybody's winters not
just yours
but um
it was nice that's a that's a piece of
americana legit
and it's like wow that little and you
can see too so i started walking the
neighborhood because someone told me
about it a little bit i'm smoking my
weed and just walking these people's
property you know streets
and then there's a still one steel mill
down the hill and it's like oh so
everybody used to probably just work
that steel mill come up to that
neighborhood there and yeah yeah
everyone had houses i mean being back in
buffalo for the first time in two years
you see that that too like with the
architecture and everything like that
you're like oh man this is like
so old compared to la you know
everything here is like post
i don't know vietnam i feel like when i
go to san diego i'm like this is a brand
new city yeah i really feel like it's a
brand new phoenix
i'm talking this dude on his balcony
or his porch he's got a like a man you
did a great job with your house he's
like thank you i'm like you really did
you stand out man i'm down there looking
up and he's like thanks man i go he's
like is this and then he tells me there
was a toy store or i kept saying toy
story christmas story two yeah there is
there is but it's like a summer thing or
something yeah it's like i
forgot around the
yeah i think charles grodin played the
dad in that one or maybe the dad came
back i can't remember but it was more
about the dogs and the bumpuses next
year
i mean they have maximized the
merchandise they sell that stuffed
bloodhound yeah oh yeah for sure for
sure dude thank you again thanks for
having me dude uh happy holidays happy
holidays new year to you and happy
holidays and happy new year to all you
please plug whatever you like i'm
excited for the new year i'm gonna have
a patreon launch in the new year there's
a lot of uh it'll be like one whole new
podcast a week and then i'm gonna do
gambling content and sports content on
there like almost like
as often as i can so that'll just be
like popping on here and there but
you'll always get a podcast once a week
a different podcast than the one i
already have and the one i already have
isn't gonna change so if you subscribe
on youtube the josh potter show
uh that's free and you can get that
every tuesday and then also i'm gonna be
coming live to milwaukee on the 23rd of
january the 30th of january i'll be in
new york at west nyack levity live the
2nd of february pittsburgh improv 3rd of
february raleigh improv so those are the
ones for sale right now so go get those
tickets at josh underscore potter on
instagram and jay underscore potter on
twitter all right as always ryan
sickler.com ryan sickler on all social
media have a safe and happy new year and
come out and see me on tour
tickets available ryancical.com talk to
y'all next week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you